In Dostowski's book Crime and Punishment
His main character
Raskolnikov
Decides that he will commit a crime and has a good case for the crime
Dostoyevsky, very good at this, is putting his characters in
Ethical attitudes are very difficult, and give them a complete justification to follow (quest) ......
Follow the moral path they follow, as Raskolnikov is bankrupt and starving and wants to go to law school
And his sister is about to
To get herself a bit of prostitution by marrying a man who hates her, dislikes him, and has towards her committed
Or such acts, he is trying to save his mother who also suffers under financial constraints
He goes to the present to mortgage his broken possessions so that he can barely survive
She has this nephew, I think he was her nephew
He was not very smart, and was basically treated as a slave, and was appalling towards him.
The current has this money that Raskolnikov badly needs him, thinking: Look !, I will just kill her. Why not the hell?!.
I will take her money she does not do any good by any way originally, I will free her nephew who lives as a slave,
She has all those people attached to her store charts, all that will happen is that the world will sacrifice a better place!
The only thing that prevents me is the traditional moral cheese.
And you know! Dostoevsky has a personality in crime and punishment
For days, hours, days, and weeks,
Strong imaginations about this rationality, about his attempt to justify
Putting himself outside the law, so that he can commit this act, he says to himself
Through the best of nihilistic arguments, that the only thing possible, which prevents him
It is a moral concept of mating (religion)
So Dostoevsky explores how he committed the crime and later of course, all the gates of hell are blooming because of
That things necessarily do not become as you want, anyway it goes unpunished
Well, he survives
Technically because no one knows that he is the one who did it, but he does not survive by considering his personal conscience
So the rest of the book explores it. Well, Dostoevsky, I think he was in crime and punishment though
He explains the issue with a number of his books, he evaluates an articular point, and this kind of issues
Which I think people who have not achieved these things especially
Literally with its philosophical path, never wrestling with it, Dostoevsky said it explicitly
If there is no God, if there is no higher value, say that if there is no lofty value, then you can do whatever you want.
And that question is
Check it out. And you see that I own
So aborted! To move people like Sam Hars, that radical atheist, because they seem to believe
That once human beings have abandoned their foundation
In lofty values, that the forward-looking path is a kind of zero
Rational, automatic, as if I do not understand it !, they believe
this is
It is the rational course! What irrationality in hell is to take exactly what I want from each of you whenever I want
At every possible moment, is not this irrational ?, and why this
More rational than our cooperation so that we can both collect a good time of it, I do not understand this!
I mean, as if insane madness is irrational !, there is nothing irrational about it!
It's a naked personal interest, how is this irrational ?, I do not understand it.
Where is the path of rationality to the virtue of Cao!
Why the hell does anyone take care of himself only, and the devil take the hindmost
It is a fully coherent philosophy.
And in fact a philosophy that you can establish in the world with a kind of material success if you want to do so.
So I do not. I do not see, for me I think the universe that people like Dockins and Hares
Dwellers, is severely conditioned by mythological preconceived assumptions.
So that they take in the abstract
The ethics that emerge from this are given, rationally recognized. And of course
What Nietzsche noted as Dystoevsky, this note Nietzsche!
You just do not understand it! The moral that you think is normative is the end result
Of nesting within this amazingly long history, many of which are expressed in
Legendary formations, you hold this !, you can not keep pro-active assumptions and just assume they are rational axioms.
The rational ..
To make a rational argument, start with a preliminary proposal
Well, the proposal that underpins Western culture is that there is a "moral value" in ethics,
You can say that this is a transcendent morality represented in God, that is fine.
You can even call it a moral diagnosis (making ethics an entity or a person) if you want to
If you do not want to move to abstract space, I do not want to argue about the existence of a god
I argue that the ethics that guide
Our culture
Based on the idea of ​​the existence of God, and that you can not only remove this idea and expect the survival of the thing (ethics) is not palpable
Without institutional consolidation (without establishing the argument).